Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History, the 12 days of Christmas, or in our case the 13 days of Christmas, because we couldn't decide when to begin and end it. We have now, of course, reached the 29th of December, which is when you're probably listening to this. And Tom Holland, I think you may have chosen a subject very close to my heart, an event that happened on this day, on the 29th of December, many centuries ago, with which I have a very profound personal connection. Am I right?
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》圣誕十二日特辑，在我们这里其实是圣誕十三日特辑，因为我们无法决定从什么时候开始、什么时候结束。当然，现在我们已经到了12月29日，这大概也是你正在收听这期节目的日子。汤姆·霍兰，我想你可能选择了一个非常贴近我心的主题——一个多世纪前的今天，即12月29日发生的一件事件，它与我有非常深厚的个人联系。我没说错吧？
You are right, Dominic. It is the murder of Thomas Beckett, which has been a great theme of poetry and drama over the years. T.S. Elliot's great play, of course, murder in the cathedral. Um, but there was another play, wasn't that?
你没说错，多米尼克。这就是托马斯·贝克特遇刺案，多年来，这一直是诗歌和戏剧的重要主题。当然，还有T·S·埃利奥特（T.S. Eliot）的伟大戏剧《大教堂谋杀案》（Murder in the Cathedral）。嗯，不过还有另一部戏剧，不是吗？
It was an absolutely first class play. I think you'll find in which you played the archbishop. So, uh, perhaps you'd like to tell the listeners about this for the umpteenth time. How many times you tell this story? I think this is about the second time, Tom only.
那真是一部绝对一流的戏剧。我想你会发现，你在这部剧中饰演了大主教。所以，呃，也许你想向听众们第无数次地讲述这件事。你讲过多少次这个故事了？汤姆，我想这大概才第二次吧。
I think it's at least the fourth. Uh, so the French playwright, Jean An the second time, Tom, only. I think it's at least the fourth. So the French playwright Jean Anouilh wrote a play called Beckett, or Beckett, as he would no doubt have called it. What would you have called it? Beckett. And he was writing, I can't remember, the 50s or the 60s, and he very much is writing in the sort of aftermath of the Second World War,
我觉得至少第四次了。呃，所以法国剧作家让·安努伊——等一下，汤姆，第二次。我觉得至少第四次了。所以法国剧作家让·安努伊（Jean Anouilh）写了一部名为《贝克特》（Becket）的戏剧，或者如他毫无疑问会发音的那样。你会怎么读？贝克特。他在写作时——我不记得了，是50年代还是60年代——他非常明显是在第二次世界大战之后的那种余波中创作的，
French resistance, and he casts Thomas Beckett. He has a lot of stuff about the Normans and the Saxons. The Normans are kind of sort of Nazi occupiers. And the Saxons are the French. Are sort of resistance, exactly. And Beckett ends up working, collaborating with the king, and then he refinds his sort of saxonness and when he finds god and he ends up being martyred so i was in a production of this um that went to the edinburgh
法国抵抗运动，他把托马斯·贝克特塑造……他有很多关于诺曼人和撒克逊人的内容。诺曼人有点像是纳粹占领者。而撒克逊人则是法国人。有点像是抵抗力量，完全是这样。最后，贝克特开始与国王合作、共事，然后他重新找到了自己身上撒克逊人的特质，当他找到了上帝，他最终殉道了。所以我在这样一个制作中参演了，呃，这部剧去了爱丁堡
festival so i think we did two weeks of rehearsals was it only with it might have been a month of rehearsals in london beforehand they went very badly i think it's fair to say and about a week to go before we went to edinburgh the, who later ended up directing Paddington, he said, this isn't working at all. This is an absolute shambles. We desperately need to rescue this. And what we'll do is... I mean, he did what basically all student plays do when they're desperate.
艺术节，所以我想我们排练了两周，或者说在伦敦可能只有一个月的排练时间？可以公平地说，那次排练进展非常糟糕。距离我们去爱丁堡大约还有一周的时候，那位后来执导了《帕丁顿熊》（Paddington）的导演说：“这根本行不通。这简直是一团糟。我们急需挽救这个局面。我们要做的就是……”我的意思是，他做了基本上所有陷入绝境的学生剧团都会做的事。
He said, let's set it very explicitly in the Third Reich. Ah, yes. And have people dressed as Nazis and all this sort of thing. And I can remember bitterly opposing this, but I was completely outvoted by the rest of the cast, which made me feel very miserable. So we arrived in Edinburgh and we did it towards,
他说：“让我们把它非常明确地设定在第三帝国吧。”啊，是的。让大家穿上纳粹的服装以及诸如此类的东西。我记得我曾对此进行过极其激烈的反对，但我被剧组的其他所有人彻底投票否决了，这让我感到非常痛苦。于是我们到达了爱丁堡，并且我们演出时，
I think it's fair to say, quite small audiences. Was it received with critical plaudits? Well, the Scotsman reviewed it and gave it two stars out of five. And as regular listeners will know, they said teenage bishops and trainers did not exactly convey the majesty of the medieval church. And, you know, I could have played Paddington off the back of that, but it wasn't to me.
可以公平地说，观众非常少。它受到评论界的赞誉了吗？嗯，《苏格兰人报》（The Scotsman）对它进行了评论，给出了五星中的两星。正如老听众们所知，他们说“身穿运动鞋的十几岁大主教并没有真正传达出中世纪教会的威严”。而且，你知道的，我本可以凭此去演《帕丁顿熊》，但事与愿违。
It should have been different. Yeah, but... Well, so I think that this is an entirely worthy subject, the murder of Thomas Beckett. Yeah, the murder of... Both for the role that it's played in your life yeah well but also as a key event in i think some critics would say he was he's been murdered twice once by henry the second knights and once by some some draw some some students from england but clearly not because because the director of Paddington, a wonderful film, obviously thought that your performance
本来应该不一样的。是啊，但是……好吧，所以我觉得这是一个完全值得探讨的主题，也就是托马斯·贝克特的谋杀案。是的，谋杀……不仅因为它在你的人生中扮演的角色，是的，好吧，但它也是一个关键事件——我想有些评论家会说他被谋杀过两次：一次死于亨利二世的骑士之手，另一次死于几个来自英国的学生的摧残。但显然不是，因为《帕丁顿熊》的导演——一部非常棒的电影，显然认为你的表演
was charismatic and powerful enough that you could play him at Beth. Yeah, and Paddington. Well, and Paddington. I'm assuming that. You're slightly extrapolating. I'm assuming that, yeah. I mean, it seems to be obvious
足够有魅力、足够有力量，以至于你能扮演他。贝思。对，还有帕丁顿熊。嗯，还有帕丁顿熊。我假设是这样的。你有点过度推断了。我假设是这样的，对。我的意思是，这似乎显而易见，
that he would have wanted me to play Paddington after I met Beth. Okay. But that offer has never explicitly been made. Dominic, have you talked enough about your... Probably not, actually. Is there anything else you'd like to... Do you want to talk about...
他会希望我在见到贝思之后去演《帕丁顿熊》。好吧。但这个提议从来没有明确提出过。多米尼克，你是不是已经聊够了你的……其实可能还没有。你还有什么想说的吗？你想聊聊……
Shall we talk about Thomas Beckett? Talk about Thomas Beckett. Who is Thomas Beckett for those people who are still listening? Okay, so Thomas Beckett. We talked about him in the World Cup of Kings because, of course, his great opponent. That's our friend, opponent, um Henry II and Thomas Beckett is a Londoner so he grew up not far from Cornhill where we were for our Christmas Carol episode um
我们要聊聊托马斯·贝克特吗？聊聊托马斯·贝克特。对于那些还在收听的听众来说，托马斯·贝克特是谁？好吧，那就是托马斯·贝克特。我们在国王世界杯（World Cup of Kings）中聊过他，因为当然，他伟大的对手……那是我们的老朋友、对手，呃，亨利二世。托马斯·贝克特是个伦敦人，所以他成长的地方离我们录制《圣诞颂歌》（A Christmas Carol）节目的康希尔（Cornhill）不远，呃，
so he grew up on on cheap side I see him like Roe Winston or Danny Dyer I think I don't think he was like Danny Dyer but I yeah that's kind of nice Danny Dyer, but yeah, that's kind of a nice idea. And he was a kind of hung out with Henry II. Henry II felt he was very much his creature because he was, you know, relatively speaking of humble stock, makes him chancellor. And then Henry is having a massive run in with the Pope, with the church, and thinks it would be a tremendous wheeze to appoint Thomasomas to um become archbishop of canterbury on the assumption that thomas will continue to you know be a lad and do what henry wants so they're carousing and stuff together aren't they oh that kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah they're kind of massive lads together the moment he becomes archbishop thomas becomes this deeply saintly figure and he takes Henry on and relations between them get worse and worse.
所以他是在齐普赛街（Cheapside）长大的。我觉得他有点像罗·温斯顿（Ray Winstone）或者丹尼·戴尔（Danny Dyer）。我不认为他像丹尼·戴尔，但我，嗯，那倒是个挺不错的想法。丹尼·戴尔，不过，是的，那倒是个挺不错的想法。他和亨利二世关系很铁。亨利二世觉得他完全是自己一手提拔的人，因为他（你知道的）相对来说出身卑微，亨利让他当了大法官。然后，亨利与教皇、与教会发生了激烈的冲突，觉得任命托马斯为坎特伯雷大主教绝对是个妙招，因为他认为托马斯会继续（你知道的）当个花花公子，按亨利的意思办事。所以他们以前经常一起寻欢作乐之类的，对吧？哦，诸如此类的事情，对，对，对。他们以前是一帮特别铁的哥们儿。但就在托马斯成为大主教的那一刻，他变成了一个极其圣洁的人物，他与亨利正面交锋，两人之间的关系变得越来越糟糕。
And Thomas ends up going into exile. And it's a terrible business. And by 1170, negotiations between Henry II, the Pope, Thomas, the King of France, all the kind of various people who are embroiled in this, what's become a massive international scandal. They've patched together, I guess, what is the kind of medieval equivalent of a Brexit deal in that it's just about looks as though, you know, it's kind of okay, but there are all kinds of problems with it
最终托马斯流亡海外。这真是一团糟。到了1170年，亨利二世、教皇、托马斯、法国国王以及所有被卷入这场已演变成巨大国际丑闻的各方人士之间的谈判，拼凑出了解决方案——我猜这大概相当于中世纪版本的“英国脱欧协议”，因为事情看起来好像（你知道的）还算可以，但其中存在着各种各样的问题，
and hostages to fortune. So this is in 1170. And 1st of December, Thomas lands back in England at Sandwich. And he travels along the road to Canterbury. And he's greeted ecstatically by the people of Kent, who all kind of hail him as the friend of widows and the patron of orphans and all this kind of stuff. And one chronicler compares him to Christ entering Jerusalem on Palm Sunday. So this doesn't obviously improve the mood.
并且留下了后患。所以这是在1170年。12月1日，托马斯在英格兰的桑威奇（Sandwich）登陆。他沿路前往坎特伯雷。肯特的民众对他进行了狂热的欢迎，所有人都把他尊为寡妇之友、孤儿的保护人以及诸如此类的人物。一位编年史家将他比作在圣枝主日（Palm Sunday）进入耶路撒冷的基督。所以这显然没有改善当时的气氛。
Yeah, Henry must be delighted by this. It doesn't improve the... Well, Henry's not delighted, but also there are other people. There's a guy called Ranulf de Brock, who's a local landowner, who's been given a castle called Saltwood, which traditionally belongs to the Archbishops of Canterbury.
是的，亨利对此一定很高兴。这并没有改善……嗯，亨利可高兴不起来，而且还有其他人。有个叫拉努尔夫·德·布罗克（Ranulf de Brok）的当地地主，他被赐予了一座名为索尔特伍德城堡（Saltwood Castle）的城堡，这座城堡传统上属于坎特伯雷大主教。
Doesn't that end up being owned by Alan Clark? It does. Yes, it does. And Jane Clark, his wife, still lives there to this day. It's where David Davis went all around the battlements while drunk. Really? So, yeah, it has a very checkered history. But Roger, Ralph de Broglie is obviously not pleased at having Beckett back.
那座城堡后来不是被艾伦·克拉克（Alan Clark）买下了吗？确实是的。是的，没错。他的妻子简·克拉克至今仍住在那里。大卫·戴维斯（David Davis）曾醉醺醺地绕着那里的城墙走。真的吗？所以，是的，它有着一段非常曲折的历史。但罗杰——拉努尔夫·德·布罗克显然对贝克特的回归很不高兴。
And he's busy stirring up trouble with Henry, who's just over the channel in Normandy. And there are various other people who are also furious with Thomas, chief of whom are three bishops. So the Archbishop of York, the Bishop of London, and the Bishop of Salisbury. Oh, Salisbury. Yeah, I'm afraid the Bishop of Salisbury doesn't come out of this well.
他正忙着在亨利面前挑拨离听，当时亨利就在海峡对岸的诺曼底。还有其他各种各样对托马斯恨之入骨的人，其中最主要的是三位主教。即约克大主教、伦敦主教和索尔兹伯里主教。哦，索尔兹伯里。对，恐怕索尔兹伯里主教在这件事里没落得什么好名声。
Oh, dear. So they have been in York, and they have crowned Henry's son, who's also called Henry, as king. Henry the Young King. Henry the Young King. I think he's about 15 or something. So he's kind of a teenager. And Thomas is livid about this because only the Archbishop of Canterbury can crown kings of England. That's the rule. Archbishop of York can't muzzle in. So he's furious about this. He demands an apology. They refuse to apologise. So Thomas excommunicates them. And he's done this even before he lands in England. The three bishops come down. They have a big bust up with Thomas.
哦，天哪。所以他们一直在约克，并且他们为亨利的儿子——也叫亨利——加冕为国王。年轻的亨利国王。年轻的亨利国王。我想他大约15岁左右。所以他差不多是个青少年。托马斯对此怒不可遏，因为只有坎特伯雷大主教才能为英格兰国王加冕。这是规矩。约克大主教不能插手。所以他对此暴跳如雷。他要求对方道歉。他们拒绝道歉。于是托马斯将他们逐出教会。甚至在他登陆英格兰之前他就这么做了。这三位主教南下，与托马斯发生了激烈的争吵。
They then go storming off. They take ship. They cross to Normandy. They come to Henry and they say that the bust up hasn't just it's not been about the argument about who should do the crowning, the Archbishop of Canterbury or the Archbishop of York. It's been because Thomas is questioning whether Henry has the right to be crowned as king. So Henry feels that the entire legitimacy of his dynasty is being questioned.
随后他们怒气冲冲地离开。他们乘船，横渡海峡来到诺曼底，找到亨利并告状。他们说这场争吵不仅仅是关于谁来主持加冕礼的争端——究竟该由坎特伯雷大主教还是约克大主教来主持。而是因为托马斯在质疑亨利是否有权加冕为王。于是亨利觉得他整个王朝的合法性都受到了质疑。
Yeah. Even though this is a bare face. Are they making this up? They're basically making it up. What, snakes? The Bishop of Salisbury, what a snake. Yeah, and do you know what the uncle of the Bishop of Salisbury says when he hears this?
是的。尽管这是一个厚颜无耻的谎言。他们在捏造事实吗？他们基本上就是在捏造。什么，毒蛇？索尔兹伯里主教，真是个阴险的小人。对，你知道索尔兹伯里主教的叔叔听到这话时是怎么说的吗？
The only way to deal with such a man is to hang him on a gibbet. He's not wrong. Yeah, if it had been true, but it wasn't true. Oh, he's talking about Beckett. I thought he was talking about the Bishop of Salisbury. No, he's talking about Beckett. Oh, that's poor. So there's this kind of rhubarb rhubarb, which you'd know as an actor.
“对付这样的人，唯一的办法就是把他吊在绞刑架上。”他说得没错。对，如果那是真的话，但那并不是真的。哦，他在说贝克特。我还以为他在说索尔兹伯里主教呢。不，他在说贝克特。哦，那可真够差劲的。所以这里有一堆像“啦啦巴巴”一样的吵闹声，作为一个演员，你肯定很熟悉。
Of course. From all the kind of the aristocrats and people at Henry's court. And we have various reports as to what Henry then said. Does he say, who will rid me of this turbulent priest? Well, he either says, what miserable drones and traitors have I nourished and promoted in my realm, who let their lord be treated with such shameful contempt by a lowborn clerk? Oh, that's strong. That's good.
当然。来自亨利宫廷的各种贵族和随从。我们有关于亨利当时到底说了什么的各种报告。他是不是说：“谁能帮我摆脱这个桀骜不驯的神甫？”嗯，他要么是说：“我在我的王国里养育和提拔了何等可悲的废物和叛徒，他们竞让自己的领主受到一个出身卑微的小文吏如此可耻的蔑视？”哦，这话说得很重。这句很好。
I like that. A man who has eaten my bread, who came to my court poor, and I have raised him high. Now he draws up his heel to kick me in the teeth. He has shamed my kin, shamed my realm. The grief goes to my heart and no one has avenged me. That's also strong and good. Good lines. How many cowardly, useless drones have I nourished that not even a single one is willing to avenge me
我喜欢这个。一个吃过我的面包、空手来到我宫廷、而我将他高高托起的人。现在他却抬起脚跟来踢我的脸。他羞辱了我的亲族，羞辱了我的王国。这悲伤直刺我心，而竟无人为我复仇。”这也是又重又好。台词真棒。我有多少懦弱无用的废物供养着，竟然连一个人都不愿意为我复仇，
of the wrongs i have suffered so those are the three reports from contemporaries so he never says who will rid me of this turbulent priest nope uh 18th century well that's a revelation to me that so in this entire podcast series going going back to when we started 2020, this is the most exciting thing I've learned. Yeah. It's overturned my previous convictions. That's what this podcast is all about, isn't it? Yeah, it's pushed back against the herd mentality
洗刷我所遭受的委屈？所以这是来自同时代人的三份报告。所以他从来没有说过“谁能帮我摆脱这个桀骜不驯的神甫”？没有。呃，18世纪——好吧，这对我是个全新的启示，在这整个播客系列中，追溯到我们2020年刚开始的时候，这是我学到的最令人兴奋的事情。是的。它彻底颠覆了我之前的信念。这正是这个播客的意义所在，不是吗？是的，它打破了那种盲从的心态，
that had taken root in my mind. But two of those statements kind of point out why Henry is particularly furious, and that is that he's a massive snob. Yeah. Because what he's harping on. A low born. Exactly.
这种心态以前已经在我的脑海中扎根了。但其中两项声明某种程度上指出了为什么亨利会如此愤怒，那就是他是个十足的势利眼。是的。因为他一直在喋喋不休地强调……出身卑微。完全正确。
So he's harping on the fact that it's not just that Thomas is opposing him. It's the fact that he's low born, that he dares to stand up to me, the king. Henry II is Virginia Woolf. That is what is driving him. Yes. Well, it's all in Kent as well, isn't it? So that basically is what's pissing Henry off. And he's having one of his rages.
所以他一直在唠叨，不仅是因为托马斯在反对他，而是因为托马斯出身卑微，却居然敢顶撞我这个国王。亨利二世简直就是弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）。这就是驱使他的原因。是的。嗯，这件事在肯特也闹得沸沸扬扬，不是吗？所以这基本上就是惹恼亨利的地方。他正在发飙。
And he's prone to rages. You know, he'll kind of pull his clothes off and eat straw and spit and scream and jibber and punch the wall. That's very unbecoming behavior from a Plantagenet warlord. Well, John does it as well, doesn't he? I mean, all the Plantagenets are giving to kind of chewing straw and hitting walls with fists. So anyway, that's basically what Henry's doing.
而且他很容易大发雷霆。你知道的，他会扯掉自己的衣服、吃稻草、吐口水、尖叫、胡言乱语、拳打墙壁。作为金雀花王朝的军事统帅，这种行为实在是太不得体了。嗯，约翰王也会这么做，不是吗？我的意思是，所有的金雀花王朝成员都有嚼稻草、挥拳砸墙的倾向。所以无论如何，这基本上就是亨利当时在做的事。
And most people, when he gets in a mood like this, they know better than to take him seriously. But there are four knights who are of obscure background who don't know henry well who are not versed in in his character who are keen to make a mark for themselves so reginald fitz earths william de tracy richard britto and hugh de morville anyway so these four knights um get on their horses go galloping um to the channel get on their horses, go galloping to the channel, get on ship, cross over, where they rendezvous in Saltwood Castle,
而且大多数人在他情绪变成这样的时候，都很清楚不要把他当真。但有四个出身卑微的骑士，他们对亨利并不了解，对他的性格也并不熟稔，急于想为自己立功——雷金纳德·菲茨乌尔斯（Reginald Fitzurse）、威廉·德·特拉西（William de Tracy）、理查德·布里托（Richard Brito）和于格·德·莫维尔（Hugh de Morville）。总之，这四位骑士跨上战马，一路疾驰，前往海峡，跨上战马，一路疾驰前往海峡，登船渡海，在索尔特伍德城堡汇合，
hang out with Ranulf de Broc. Right. And they then head on to Canterbury and they arrive there in the afternoon. And Ranulf de Broc brings all his men-at-arms with him and they seal off the city, essentially so that Thomas won't be able to escape. The knights go bursting into
和拉努尔夫·德·布罗克混在一起。没错。然后他们继续赶往坎特伯雷，在下午抵达。拉努尔夫·德·布罗克带着他所有的武装随从一同前往，封锁了整个城市，本质上是为了防止托马斯逃跑。这些骑士怒气冲冲地闯入
the Archbishop's Hall where Thomas is kind of hanging out. They confront him. Thomas very much holds his own, sends them packing. They're not thrilled by that. They go out. They then try to break back in. But by this point, it's all been locked up.
大主教的大厅，托马斯当时正待在那里。他们与他当面对质。托马斯非常镇定地稳住阵脚，把他们打发走了。他们对此很不高兴，气冲冲地走了出去。然后他们试图再次破门而入。但到了这个时候，所有门窗都已经锁上了。
So they traipse through an orchard. They climb up a ladder. They break in that way. But by this point, Thomas has gone to Vespers. Yeah. And he walks into the cathedral. And the various monks bar the doors behind them because they're worried about what's going to happen. And Thomas says, no, open.
于是他们穿过一座果园，爬上一架梯子，从那里强行闯入。但此时，托马斯已经去参加晚祷了。是的。他走进大教堂，身后的几位僧侣把大门关上并插上门栓，因为他们担心会发生什么。托马斯说：“不，打开。”
You know, this is the Church of God. It must be open to all comers. So he orders the bolts to be slid open, doors to be opened so that he knows what he's doing. He's courting martyrdom. And the lights come in. Beckett could easily have fled. I mean, he could easily have hidden. It's very dark by this point.
“你知道的，这是上帝的教堂。它必须对所有来访者敞开。”因此他命令拉开门栓，把门打开，他心里很清楚自己在做什么。他在自寻殉道。而骑士们冲了进来。贝克特本来完全可以逃跑的。我的意思是，他完全可以躲起来。那时候天已经很黑了。
You know, shadows are lengthening. Yeah. But he doesn't. He stands his ground and he gets kind of brutally murdered. And we've already talked about this, about how there is one blow that is so brutal that it slices through the crown of his skull. So like the top of an egg being sliced off with a knife. And the sword comes down with such force that it sends sparks flying in the air. And so his brains start to seep out across the floor. And one of the other knights then takes his sword and scrapes all the brains out of the skull. This is a very, this is meant to be a festive podcast, Tom.
你知道的，阴影正在拉长。是的。但他没有逃。他坚守阵地，然后遭到了残酷的谋杀。我们之前已经讨论过这一点，其中有一击是如此凶狠，竟然劈开了他的头骨顶部。就像用刀削掉鸡蛋顶部一样。宝剑带着巨大的力量砍下来，在空中激起了火花。于是他的脑浆开始在地板上渗流出来。接着，另一位骑士拔出剑，把头骨里的脑浆全刮了出来。这太……这本该是一个喜庆的播客，汤姆。
It kind of is. I mean, it's one of the great feast days, the Master of Beckett, that then gets forgotten with the Reformation, obviously. Have you seen the version of this in The Blackadder? No. The medieval first series of what becomes Blackadder. I must have done. So in that, Edmund Rowan Atkinson
某种程度上确实是。我的意思是，这是伟大的瞻礼日之一，也就是贝克特的瞻礼日，不过后来随着宗教改革，它显然被人们淡忘了。你看过《黑爵士》（The Blackadder）里的那个版本吗？没有。中世纪背景的第一季《黑爵士》。我一定看过的。所以在那一集里，埃德蒙——罗温·、艾金森（Rowan Atkinson）
is made Archbishop of Canterbury, and knights attack him. But he and Baldrick and Percy, his mates disguise themselves as nuns. Well, that doesn't happen with Thomas. He very bravely accepts his martyrdom. Yeah.
被任命为坎特伯雷大主教，骑士们袭击了他。但他、鲍德里克（Baldrick）和他的死党珀西（Percy）伪装成修女。好吧，托马斯可没发生这种事。他非常勇敢地接受了自己的殉道。是的。
And, you know, the guy who is Hugh de Morville, I think it is, is scraping the brains out with his sword. And he shouts, he keeps yelling out, he won't be getting up again. he won't be getting up again.
而且，你知道的，那个叫于格·德·莫维尔的家伙——我想是他吧——正用剑刮着脑浆。他大喊着，不停地大喊：“他再也站不起来了！
He won't be getting up again. No. As he kind of spatters the brains all over the floor. So that's the martyrdom of Thomas. They go galloping off into the night. Henry, of course, has brought the news and he goes, oh, I wasn't sure about, I mean, he pretends to be terribly upset.
他再也站不起来了！”当他把脑浆溅得到处都是的时候。这就是托马斯的殉道。他们骑着马在夜色中飞驰而去。亨利当然得到了消息，他说：“哦，我不是那个意思……”我的意思是，他假装难过得无以复加。
I don't think he is particularly. He's probably slightly relieved that Thomas has gone. I think he is relieved. I think he is relieved. But he also knows that this is open to terrible kind of. Well, yes, because immediately Thomas's relics start to perform miracles. Yeah. And it spontaneously becomes this great place of pilgrimage.
我觉得他并没有那么难过。他可能甚至有点暗自庆幸托马斯终于死了。我想他是松了一口气的。我想他是松了一口气的。但他同时也知道，这会带来可怕的……嗯，是的，因为托马斯的圣遗物立刻开始显灵行神迹了。是的。这里自发地成了一个伟大的朝圣地。
And in the end, Henry submits to um you know the public humiliation of walking barefoot through canterbury and being birched by monks and things simply so that he can kind of buy into the charisma of the martyred archbishop um and so it remains you know the great center of pilgrimage for centuries and centuries it's it's where the Canterbury Pilgrims go in Chaucer's poem. And for obvious reasons, Henry VIII hates it. Yeah. Absolutely hates it. And so it becomes a particular object of the fury of his reformers.
最后，亨利不得不屈服于……你知道的，赤脚穿过坎特伯雷并被僧侣用枝条抽打的公开羞辱，仅仅是为了能够借用这位殉道大主教的神圣光环……所以这里依然是世世代代伟大的朝圣中心。这就是乔叟（Chaucer）的诗中坎特伯雷朝圣者们前往的地方。由于显而易见的理由，亨利八世对这里恨之入骨。是的。恨之入骨。因此，这里成了他的宗教改革派狂怒的特定攻击目标。
So I was going to ask a question about Thomas Becket. Do you think that you can draw a little line between, a faint line between Thomas Becket and people like Thomas Cromwell centuries later? Lowborn, risen up, king's sort of pal and minister. Both Londoners. Yeah, becoming involved with the church, all that stuff. Except that Thomas Cromwell is the great servant of the king.
所以我本来想问一个关于托马斯·贝克特的问题。你觉得你能在托马斯·贝克特和几个世纪后的托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）这样的人之间划出一条细细的线吗？出身卑微、平步青云、身为国王的死党兼大臣。都是伦敦人。是的，都涉足教会事务，诸如此类。只不过托马斯·克伦威尔是国王的忠实仆从。
Exactly. So in some ways, was Henry II, do you think, expecting that Thomas Beckett would behave? Would be a Cromwell, yes. Would be a Cromwell, yeah, exactly. Or a Woolsey, I think, more likely. Yeah, yeah. Yes, I think so.
完全正确。所以在某些方面，你觉得亨利二世当时是否期待托马斯·贝克特会表现得……会成为一个克伦威尔，对吧？会成为一个克伦威尔，是的，完全正确。或者更像是一个沃尔西（Wolsey）。是的，是的。是的，我想是的。
And Beckett's refusal to do that was... Well, that's certainly what I tried to work into my performance. And it's a shame that the Scotsman never recognised that. But you weren't in Murder in the Cathedral. No, I wasn't. Which is a great play, I think. I've never seen that or read it. Very powerful. no I wasn't which is a great play I've never seen that or read it very powerful
而贝克特拒绝这样做，正是……嗯，这绝对是我试图在我的表演中展现出来的东西。遗憾的是，《苏格兰人报》从来没有认出这一点。但你没有演过《大教堂谋杀案》。不，我没有。我觉得那是一部很棒的戏剧。我从未看过或读过它。非常有力量。不，我没有演过，我觉得那是一部很棒的戏剧。我从未看过或读过它。非常有力量，
great lines on how tempting it is to be a martyr right now is my way clear now is the meaning plain temptation shall not come in this kind again
台词写得极好：关于此时此刻当一个殉道者是多么具有诱惑力。“我的路现在明了了吗？意义现在清晰了吗？诱惑不会以这种形式再度降临……”
the last temptation is the greatest treason to do the right deed for the wrong reason I can imagine you saying that yeah I can in your trainers we've had poetry before,
“最后也是最大的诱惑，便是为了错误的理由去做正确的事。”我能想象你说出这句话的样子，对。我能想象你穿着运动鞋说这话的样子。我们之前聊过诗歌，
William McGonagall, and now we've had T.S. Eliot. Yeah. We've hit both the... The poetry vein. We have. Right, let's take a break and then we'll come back
威廉·麦贡纳高（William McGonagall），现在我们又聊到了T·S·埃利奥特。是的。我们既涉足了……诗歌领域。我们确实涉足了。好了，我们休息一下，接下来
with some Native Americans. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
我们将聊聊美洲原住民。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment dot com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History with our celebration
如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，和我们一起庆祝
of the 29th of December and it's a rather morbid celebration because we've already had the murder of Thomas Beckett, a rather brutal assassination in the heart of Canterbury Cathedral. And now, Dominic, you've got more. I've got a shocking story, a really brutal story.
12月29日。这是一个相当阴郁的庆祝活动，因为我们已经回顾了托马斯·贝克特遇刺案——坎特伯雷大教堂核心发生的一场相当残酷的暗杀。而现在，多米尼克，你还有更多内容。我有一个令人震惊的故事，一个极其残酷的故事。
So it's the massacre at Wounded Knee on the 29th of December, 1890. So we did a podcast earlier in the year. On the Wild West, didn't we? The Wild West that was enormously enjoyable. I loved doing that. It's such an interesting subject. And we haven't really done much American,
那就是1890年12月29日发生的伤膝河大屠杀（Wounded Knee Massacre）。我们在今年早些时候做过一期播客，
sort of Western history. And we haven't done any kind of native american history at all really have we so this is the most famous incident probably apart from the last battle of the little bighorn um probably the single most famous incident in the the sorry history of the interaction between in you know european americans and it's given its its name to the title of d brown's famous revisionist work on exactly very much in the west very much and i also thought this was a good story tom because it's kind of a gift to you because it's it's partly about the influence of christianity isn't it i know yes it is so let's set the scene a bit so we are in the kind of Great Plains of the United States.
关于美国旧西部的，不是吗？那期关于旧西部的节目非常引人入胜。我特别喜欢做那一期。这是一个如此有趣的主题。而且我们实际上没有怎么做过美洲……那种西部历史。并且我们真的没有做过任何美洲原住民的历史，不是吗？所以这大概是最著名的事件了——除了小大角战役（Battle of the Little Bighorn）的最后决战之外，大概是欧洲裔美国人与美洲原住民互动这段悲惨历史中最具标志性的单一事件。它也为迪·布朗（Dee Brown）关于这一主题的著名修正主义著作提供了书名。非常深入西部，非常深入。而且我也觉得这是一个很好的故事，汤姆，因为它对你来说简直是个天赐的礼物，因为这部分地涉及到了基督教的影响，我没说错吧？是的，确实如此。所以让我们稍微交代一下背景。我们身处美国的大平原地区。
Specifically, we are in South Dakota, what we know as South Dakota. The U.S. Army has been campaigning basically for years, for decades, to subdue the Plains Indians. The arrival of the railroads has done tremendous damage to the kind of ecosystem on which the Indians rely. So they relied, of course, on the bison and so on that's largely gone um quite deliberately right i mean yes because we talked about that in the wild west episode exactly the deliberate extermination of the bison their world has fallen apart and and their world has fallen apart deliberately because white settlers have taken it upon themselves deliberately to destroy that world.
具体来说，我们身处南达科他州，也就是我们所知的南达科他州。多年来、几十年来，美军一直在发起军事行动，基本上是为了征服平原印第安人。铁路的修建对印第安人赖以生存的生态系统造成了巨大的破坏。因此，他们当然依赖于美洲野牛等动物，而这些动物如今基本上已经消失了……这是蓄意为之的，对吧？我的意思是，是的，因为我们在旧西部那一集里谈到过这一点，对野牛的蓄意灭绝。他们的世界分崩离析了，
Often union generals, generals who've been involved in the Civil War play a big part in that. Washington politicians as well. So by this point, so let's pick up in the sort of late 1880s, the Lakota Sioux. So the Sioux, probably the most, one of the most famous. Victors of Bighorn. Indian groups. They are on reservations by and large. And they're finding that really tough.
而且他们的世界之所以分崩离析，是因为白人定居者自作主张、蓄意要摧毁那个世界。通常是由联邦将军、曾参与内战的将军们在其中发挥了重要作用。华盛顿的政客们也是如此。所以在那个时候——让我们把时间拉到1880年代末期——拉科塔苏族（Lakota Sioux）。所以苏族，可能是最著名、最有名的印第安部落之一。大角战役的胜利者。他们大体上都住在保留地里。他们发现那里的生活非常艰难。
So that basically the US government is encouraging them to become agriculturalists, to plant crops, to become basically farmers. And not to get hunting buffalo. And that's not really part of their culture. They're completely unsuited to it. They are being encouraged by federal agents, agents of the Bureau of Indian Affairs, to wear Western clothes, you know, to dress in sort of suits and trousers and stuff,
基本上，美国政府在鼓励他们成为农业人口，种植农作物，基本上是让他们成为农民。而不是去狩猎野牛。这其实并不符合他们的文化。他们完全不适合这种生活方式。联邦特工——印度事务局（Bureau of Indian Affairs）的特工们——在鼓励他们穿西方服装（你知道的，穿西装和长裤之类），
to speak English, crucially to abandon their traditional religion and to embrace Christianity. So their sort of mental and imaginative world is collapsing and they're being forced to adopt all these sort of new and strange things. But at the same time, there's a series of harsh winters and droughts and things. They don't have much food. They're reliant on government rations, which are being sort of stripped back because the government is cutting them so they're in a terrible state basically
说英语，最重要的是放弃他们的传统宗教，拥抱基督教。所以他们的精神和想象世界正在崩塌，他们被迫接受所有这些又新又奇怪的事物。但与此同时，又遭遇了一系列严寒的冬天、旱灾等自然灾害。他们没有多少食物。他们只能依赖政府的配给，而政府正在削减这些配给，因为政府在缩减开支。所以他们基本上处于一种可怕的境地。
and then at the beginning of 1890 this this this cultish movement sweeps through the reservations of the plains the ghost dance the ghost dance that's an absolutely fascinating thing it's the it has been around for a while but it is revived by a kind of indian prophet almost who's a man called wavoka now his father had been a ghost dancer and had taught his son about it his son has been raised among people who have by ranchers who have exposed him and his friends to christianity so a kind of messianic religion is is is in his mind it's in the ether after Jesus will come again and exactly and now the story goes that it's a there's a there's an eclipse on New Year's Day 1889 I think it is and he falls asleep or has uh goes into a kind of trance
然后，在1890年年初，这场带有狂热崇拜色彩的运动席卷了平原地区的保留地——那就是鬼舞（Ghost Dance）。鬼舞，这是一个绝对迷人的现象。它其实已经存在了一段时间，但它被一位堪称印第安先知的男子复兴了，这个人叫沃沃卡（Wavoka）。他的父亲曾是一位鬼舞者，并将这一切教给了他的儿子。他的儿子是在白人牧场主的抚养下长大的，牧场主曾让他和他的朋友们接触过基督教。因此，一种弥赛亚式的宗教在他的脑海中成形了，它弥漫在空气中……耶稣将再次降临，正是如此。现在传说在1889年新年那天发生了一次日食，我想是的，他睡着了或者进入了一种出神状态，
and God tells him that the if the Indians do this ritual dance, this circular dance and follow these instructions, then in two years time, God will return the earth to the state that it was in before the Americans, the white settlers arrived. And the buffalo will come back. That's what I always find so tragic. The buffalo will return and the white settlers themselves
上帝告诉他，如果印第安人们跳这种仪式性的舞蹈——这种环形舞蹈——并遵循这些指示，那么在两年后，上帝将把地球恢复到美国人、白人定居者到来之前的状态。野牛将会回来。我总是觉得这一点如此悲惨。野牛将回归，而白人定居者自己将被埋在30英尺深的泥土之下，印第安人的祖先将从死里复活。这就是为什么它被称为“鬼舞”，对吧？完全正确。现在你可以看出基督教是如何渗入其中的了——死里复活的想法、基督再临的想法，所有这些诸如此类的概念。在拉科塔苏族人中间，这成了一个具有极其强大力量的信息。人们当然渴望听到它，因为他们的生活实在太悲惨了。于是他们开始穿这种名为“鬼衣”（ghost shirts）的白色衬衫，他们把衬衫穿在身上，并在上面画上或用神圣的符号装饰它们。他们被告知、或者自己告诉自己，这些符号
will be buried under 30 feet of soil and that the Indians ancestors will rise from the dead. And that's that's why it's the ghost dance right? Right exactly. Now you can see why where Christianity may have seeped into this you know the idea of being risen from the dead the idea of the second coming all of this sort of stuff and among the Lakota Sioux this becomes an incredibly powerful message people want to hear it of course they do because their lives are so terrible so they start wearing these white shirts called ghost shirts where they put on they painted them with kind of or decorated them with sacred symbols and they are told or tell themselves that these symbols
将保护他们免受美洲军队子弹的伤害。于是，这场运动在整个1889年和1890年不断蔓延、蔓延、再蔓延。联邦特工对此感到十分恼火。他们无法理解，并为此感到忧虑，他们认为这有可能演变成某种暴动。基本上到了1890年11月，美军被派往平原地区，并接到命令：阻止鬼舞。你知道的，把他们围起来，让他们停下来。所以这方面的第一个行动，是他们试图围捕一群住在立石局（Standing Rock Agency）附近的苏族人，
will protect them against american army bullets so the movement spreads and spreads and spreads throughout 1889 1890 and the federal agents are very put out by this they don't understand it they're worried about it they think it has potential to become a kind of insurgency. And basically by November 1890, the US Army is being sent into the plains and told, stop the ghost dance. You know, round them up and get them to stop it. So the first instance of this, they try to round up a load of Sioux
他们和坐牛（Sitting Bull）在一起。坐牛是一位伟大的酋长，他曾因在1876年的小大角战役中率领印第安人击败卡斯特（Custer）和第七骑兵团而闻名遐迩。
who are living near the Standing Rock Agency with Sitting Bull, the great chief who had famously been involved, been one of the people who had led the Indians at the Battle of the Little Bighorn in 1876 when Custer and the 7th Cavalry had been
好吧，所以我想在12月15日，他们被包围了，发生了一场小规模的冲突，一些苏族人被杀，其中就包括坐牛。关于那件事有一个可怕的故事：坐牛曾和水牛比尔（Buffalo Bill）一起参加过《狂野西部秀》，所以那匹马曾被训练得听到步枪射击声就会跳舞。因此，当坐牛中枪倒地、血染尘土时，他的马开始跳舞。步枪射击声。因此，当坐牛中枪倒地、血染尘土时，他的马开始跳舞。哦，那真是一个可怕的故事，汤姆。
defeated. Well, so I think it's December the 15th, they're rounded up, there's a sort of bit of a struggle some of the Sioux are killed and one of them is Sitting Bull and there's a terrible story about that that Sitting Bull had been with Buffalo Bill
这是一个可怕的故事。苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）这一期节目真是太让人沮丧了。我知道，到处都是血迹斑斑的。事情就是这样，当这个消息传到其他苏族人和别的保留地时，他们感到无比震惊。其中一些人开始聚集起来。
on the Wild West show and so the horse had been trained to dance to the sound of rifle fire and so when Sitting Bull gets shot he falls and he's bleeding into the dust and his horse starts rifle fire. And so when Sitting Bull gets shot, he falls and he's bleeding into the dust, and his horse starts to dance. Oh, that's a terrible
他们为他们所认为的与美军的决战做好了准备。你觉得这是一种末日降临的情绪吗？我完全这么认为。他们一定知道，按照常规标准来看，他们根本毫无希望。绝对是的。我想他们绝对是这样想的。
story, Tom. It's a terrible story. This is such a depressing episode of Apple Podcasts. I know, it's just kind of blood everywhere. So there's that, and that, when that news of this reaches the other Sioux and the other reservations, they are absolutely horrified by this. Some of them start kind other reservations, they are absolutely horrified by this.
所以其中一些人可能几乎陷入了一种宗教狂热中，认为自己能赢。但我猜他们大多数人正如你所说，有一种末日感——虽算不上完全自杀，但绝对有一种末日危机感，而这当然也是这种狂热崇拜本身所固有的。当时有一个叫红云（Red Cloud）的人正试图与美国人达成某种协议。他当时在松岭保留地（Pine Ridge Reservation）。
Some of them start kind of gathering. They're prepared for what they see as a showdown with the US Army. And do you think it's in an apocalyptic mood? I think so, absolutely. They must know that they can't, you know, by conventional standards, they haven't got a hope. Absolutely. I think they absolutely.
一些印第安人正试图前往松岭保留地，以便与红云等人会合。其中一个试图前往松岭的群体是一群米尼孔朱拉科塔苏族人（Miniconjou Lakota Sioux）。他们的首领是一个叫大脚（Bigfoot）的人。所以他的真名是西坦克（Sitanka），但美国人叫他大脚。大脚带着大约350名这样的人——
So some of them perhaps are caught up with kind of religious hysteria almost and think they can win. But I suspect most of them, as you say, there is an apocalyptic, not quite suicidal, but there is definitely an apocalyptic sense, which is, of course, built into the cult. So there's a guy called Red Cloud who is trying to do a deal with the Americans. And he's on the Pine Ridge Reservation.
我说“这样的人”，是指男人、女人和儿童——他说：“让我们去松岭，与红云会合，希望事情能顺利解决吧。”他们便出发了。美国人听说他们在移动，对此感到大惊小怪，并派出了第七骑兵团——也就是曾在小大角战役中被打败的那支军队——前去拦截他们。在12月29日，他们基本上——美军第七骑兵团包围了这些人，他们说：“我们要没收你们所有的武器。”所以他们基本上把第七骑兵团包围了这些人，并说：“我们要没收你们所有的武器。”
And some of the Indians are trying to get to the Pine Ridge Reservation where they can unite with Red Cloud and so on. And one of the groups who are trying to get to Pine Ridge are a group of mini-konju Lakota Sioux. And they are led by a guy called Bigfoot. So his real name is Sitanka but the Americans name is Bigfoot. And Bigfoot gets about 350 of these guys and he says
因此他们基本上把印第安人赶进了一片开阔地。他们在开阔地周围部署了骑兵。他们架设了正对准印第安人的枪炮，因为美国人自己当然也感到害怕。他们不理解鬼舞。他们不理解印第安人。所以这一切都布置好了。第七骑兵团开始搜查他们的武器。
I say guys, men, women and children says let's get to Pine Ridge, unite with Red Cloud and hopefully it'll be okay. Off they go. The Americans hear that they're moving and get in a flap about it, and they send the 7th Cavalry, so basically the very
就在这个时候，一个名叫“直坐”（Sitz Strait）的人开始跳起鬼舞。现在你可以理解这是一种……他为什么要这么做？这是一种挑衅的行为，因为他自己也很害怕。这是一种挑衅的行为，但也许也是一种试图召唤基督再临的尝试。是的，也许，也许吧。他对其他人说，
part of the army that has been beaten at Little Bighorn to intercept them. And on the 29th of December, they basically, the American 7th Cavalry round up these people, and they'd say, we're going to confiscate all your weapons. So they get, they basically 7th Cavalry, round up these people and they'd say, we're going to confiscate all your weapons.
他对其他人说：“别担心，你知道的，我们的白衬衫意味着我们不会被美国人的子弹伤害。”于是这种舞蹈变得越来越狂热，一种盘旋旋转的舞蹈。美国士兵则变得越来越焦虑。你知道的，你几乎可以感觉到他们对手指扣动扳机时神经高度紧绷，随时准备开枪。基本上就是在那个时候，其中一个印第安人——
So they basically herd them into a clearing. They surround the clearing with cavalry. They position guns facing them because the Americans, of course, are frightened themselves. They don't understand the ghost dance. They don't understand the Indians. So it's all sort of set up. The 7th Cavalry start searching them for weapons.
一个名叫黑郊狼（Black Coyote）的男子被要求交出他的枪。他是个聋子，所以他既听不懂也没有听见。接着发生了一些事情。目前还不清楚是不是他的枪走火了——也许就是他的枪，呃——第七骑兵团由于高度紧张、随时准备开枪，你可以想象当时的场景：他们突然开始射击。一时间，地狱般的混乱爆发了，每个人都在开枪。可能在几分钟内，大部分伤亡就在一开始发生了，而且伤亡极其惨重。美国人直接开始疯狂开枪。关于当时发生了什么的记述相互矛盾，
And at this point, a man called Sitz Strait starts to dance the ghost dance. Now you can sort of, it's an act of, why is he doing it? An act of defiance because he himself is frightened. An act of defiance, but also perhaps an attempt to invoke the second coming. Yeah, maybe, maybe. And he says to the others, he's saying to the others,
关于到底发生了什么也存在种种争论。但我们确实知道，大约146名印第安人后来被埋在一个万人坑里，但总共丧生的人数可能在300左右，其中大约有一半是妇女和儿童。所以这是一场真正的大屠杀。这正是你在阅读历史上的大屠杀时常常见到的经典场景：冲突由一场意外引发，随后演变成一种令人上瘾的疯狂狂热，每个人都开始开枪，一旦他们开了枪，就无法停下来，直到所有人都死去。军官们失去了控制，所有人都在向这些毫无防备的人群倾泻子弹，至少……
don't worry, you know, our white shirts mean that we can't be hurt by the Americans' bullets. So this dance becomes more and more kind of frenzied, sort of whirling dance. And the American soldiers become more and more anxious. You know, you can almost trigger happy, sense their fingers tensing on the triggers. And basically it's at this point that one of the Indians,
别担心，你知道的，我们的白衬衫意味着我们不会被美国人的子弹伤害。于是这种舞蹈变得越来越疯狂，有点像旋转的舞蹈。而美国士兵则变得越来越焦虑。你知道的，你几乎可以感觉到他们扣动扳机的食指在紧绷，随时准备开枪。基本上就是在这种情况下，其中一个印第安人，
who's a guy called Black Coyote, is told to give up his gun. He is deaf, so he doesn't understand or hear. And something then happens. It's not clear his a gun goes off maybe it's his gun um the seventh cavalry who are so trigger happy and nervous they you can imagine the scene they start shooting suddenly all hell is breaking loose everybody is shooting probably within moments most of the casualties happen at first, and they are enormous casualties. So the Americans just start blasting away. Accounts of what happened are they conflict,
一个叫黑土狼的家伙，被要求交出他的枪。他是个聋子，所以他听不见也不明白。接着发生了一些事情。目前还不清楚他的枪是否走火了，也许是他的枪，嗯，第七骑兵队的士兵们是如此渴望开枪且神经紧绷，你能想象当时的场景，他们开始突然开枪，整个场面彻底失控，所有人都在开枪，可能在几秒钟内，大部分伤亡就在一开始发生了，而且伤亡极为惨重。于是美国人开始疯狂开火。关于当时发生的事情，各种记述存在矛盾，
and there are sort of debates about what happened. But we do know that about 146 of the Indians were later buried in a mass grave, but probably about 300 of them were killed in total and about half of them were women and children so it's a genuine massacre what it's that classic thing that you get with if ever you read about massacres in history that it starts by accident and then it becomes the kind of addictive frenzy and everybody starts shooting and once they've started they can't stop until everybody's dead um the officers lose control everybody's kind of you know pouring bullets into these defenseless people um at least
并且对于到底发生了什么也有各种争论。但我们确实知道，大约有146名印第安人后来被埋在一个万人坑里，不过总共可能有大约300人被杀，其中大约一半是妇女和儿童，所以这是一场真正的屠杀。这就是你在读到历史上的屠杀时经常见到的那种经典情况：它始于一场意外，然后演变成一种上瘾般的疯狂，每个人都开始开枪，一旦他们开始就停不下来，直到所有人都死去，嗯，军官们失去了控制，每个人都在向这些毫无防御的人倾泻子弹，至少
about 25 of the american soldiers themselves were killed probably by their own side because i mean they're in a circle so they're almost firing on each other so it's this horrendous scene um and what happens at first is the bureau of indian affairs says it's basically a battle we were attacked by indians and we were defending ourselves but very soon it comes out that it was a massacre and it becomes this terrible sort of stain um well because also i mean it it draws the line under direct combat doesn't it yeah it Yeah, it does. It's the last, it's always the final chapter of every book. But also, I mean, if you were writing a script of the tragedy of the Native Americans in the United States,
大约有25%的美国士兵自己人被杀，可能是被他们自己的一方误杀，因为我的意思是他们在围成一个圈，所以他们几乎是在互相开枪，这是一个极其恐怖的场面。起初发生的事情是，印第安人事务局说，这基本上是一场战斗，我们遭到印第安人的袭击，我们在进行自卫。但很快真相大白，这是一场大屠杀，这就成了一个可怕的污点。嗯，因为这也划清了直接战斗的界限，不是吗？是的，确实如此。这是最后一部分，它总是每一本书的最后一章。但同时，我的意思是，如果你要为美国原住民的悲剧写一个剧本，
you couldn't have written a more moving or upsetting climax to it, really. Exactly right. It's the perfect, in a way, it's kind of microcosm, or it's kind of metaphor for that. Yeah, kind of blood seeping out into the snow. For the wider story. Exactly, very miserable. The guy who was the commanding officer of Grogor for Scythe,
你简直写不出一个更感人、更令人心碎的高潮了。完全正确。在某种程度上，它是一个完美的微观缩影，或者说是其中的一种隐喻。是的，鲜血渗入雪地中的那种景象。为了更宏大的故事。完全正确，非常凄惨。那个担任格罗戈尔指挥官的人，
there's an investigation into him. He's temporarily stripped of his command. But, you know, the investigation finds that he was innocent and he's restored to his post. So, you know, that in a way is not surprising that's exactly always going to happen because in a way i don't want to be too strident about this but what's undoubtedly true is that in the 19th century i think white sort of european americans didn't really admit to themselves the extent of what was happening to the indians is it's still not it's it we talked about this in the wild west podcast
对他也展开了调查。他被暂时撤销了指挥权。但是，你知道，调查发现他是无辜的，他又恢复了职务。所以，你知道，在某种程度上这并不令人意外，这总是会发生，因为某种程度上——我不想对此表现得过于激烈——毫无疑问的是，在19世纪，我认为白人即欧裔美国人并没有真正向自己承认印第安人遭遇的严重程度，现在也依然没有，我们在“狂野西部”播客中讨论过这一点，
you know the great american sin is is perceived as being slavery isn't it and um the arguments about the african americans sort of place in the united states their history in the united states they're incredibly resonant and contested and all of this. And what happened to the Native Americans, it feels like a smaller story, doesn't it? It doesn't get discussed as much. It doesn't get, there aren't such high profile campaigns. It's not, but it should be. But because there aren't as many.
你知道，美国最大的罪孽被认为是奴隶制，对吧？关于非裔美国人在美国所处的地位、他们在美利坚历史上的地位的争论，是极具回响性和争议性的。而原住民的遭遇，感觉像是一个较小的话题，不是吗？它没有得到那么多讨论，也没有引起那么大范围的运动。它不是，但它本该是的。不过是因为人数没那么多。
I mean, and we know why there aren't as many because it will been wiped out yeah um but i'm kind of thinking there are certain you know certain kind of parallels between the two stories the two um periods that we've looked at um and one is that there's a there's a kind of sense of delayed acknowledgement of guilt on on the part of henry ii and he kind of says yeah okay it's it's a terrible thing whatever and then it's delayed acknowledgement of guilt on the part of Henry II. And he kind of says, yeah, okay, it's a terrible thing, whatever. And then it's only gradually that he comes to realise how potent an episode it's been
我的意思是，我们也知道为什么人数没那么多，因为他们被消灭了。是的。嗯，但我在想，我们看过的这两个故事、这两个时期之间，存在着某些相似之处。其中一点就是，亨利二世对过失有一种延迟的承认感，他某种程度上说，好吧，这是一件糟糕的事情，无论如何。然后，亨利二世对过失有一种延迟的承认感。他某种程度上说，好吧，这是一件糟糕的事情，无论如何。直到后来，他才逐渐意识到这一事件有多么重大的影响，
and how he wants to get on the right side of it. And you could say that a kind of slightly similar process has happened with Wounded Knee, that it's taken time for white people, I guess, the apparatus of the United States government, however you want to put it, to fully acknowledge the scale of what happened. And to recognize that there is a kind of power in that martyrdom. Because there's a reason why it's Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee, why that's such an evocative name and why that book had such an impact to the degree that I think it'd be very difficult ever again
以及他如何想要站在正确的一边。你可以说，在“伤膝河”事件上，也发生了略微相似的过程，白人需要时间——我猜，也就是美国政府的机器，无论你怎么称呼它——来完全承认所发生事情的规模，并认识到这种殉难中蕴含着某种力量。因为，“把我埋在伤膝河畔”之所以是一个如此唤起人们共鸣的名字，这本书之所以产生如此巨大的影响，是有原因的，甚至我认为以后很难再有人去描绘那种牛仔与印第安人冲突中印第安人全是坏人的画面了。我只是觉得你再也无法那样做了。这也发生在《与狼共舞》之后，不是吗，汤姆？你不觉得《与狼共舞》吗？但我认为《与狼共舞》受《把我埋在伤膝河畔》的影响太大了。是的。我认为，你知道，这两者都有某种延迟震惊的感觉。
to portray, you know, cowboys and Indians where the Indians are the baddies. I just don't think you could ever do that again. It's also post Dancers of the Wolves though, isn't it, Tom? Don't you think Dancers of the Wolves? But I think Dancers of the Wolves was so influenced by Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee. Yeah. I think, you know, there's kind of, with both of them, I think there was a kind of sense of delayed shock.
并且在这两者中，都有这样一种感觉，那就是在某种程度上——恕我直言——殉难中有一种神圣的力量。在19世纪73年，当印第安人想要、印第安激进分子想要抗议他们所受到的待遇时，他们占领了伤膝河遗址。他们选择的就是伤膝河。抗议……我的意思是，那是在尼克松执政期间。它不是专门针对尼克松的。它是针对美国政府更广泛的种种行径。
And with both of them, there's a sense that there is a kind of, dare I say, sacral power to be had in Malmsteen. In 1973, when Indians wanted to, Indian activists wanted to protest against their treatment, they occupy the site of Wounded Knee. It's Wounded Knee that they choose. The protest against the, I mean, it's during the Nixon years. It's not specifically against Nixon. It's against the sort of the American government more generally.
以及他们的冷漠。我的意思是，他们选择这个地点出于完全可以理解的原因。是的。我想，如果斯图尔特·布朗的书能够引发对美国印第安人困境的任何真正改变，我可能会更多地相信它的这种力量。他们仍然是被遗忘的受害者，不是吗？难道你不这么认为吗？也许吧，也许吧，但我认为他们的痛苦现在比50年代时受到的关注度要高得多，而且我认为，如果你想想
And their neglect. I mean, that's the site they choose for absolutely understandable reasons. Yeah. I suppose I would buy that a bit more about its power if it had led to if recognition of since d brown's book had led to any kind of real change in the in the plight of american indians they're still the sort of forgotten victims aren't they don't you think i'd maybe maybe but i think i think they have i think that their sufferings have a much higher prominence now than they did no i did in the 50s let's say and i think i think that um if you if you think
引发的怨恨以及那种同情，也许你就会明白，当亨利八世摧毁贝克特的陵墓时，究竟有什么是处于危险之中的。殉难者的力量对于那些为此感到受到威胁的人来说是非常危险的。汤姆，把这联系起来，这绝对是英勇的壮举。没有哪个历史播客曾试图将托马斯的死与……联系起来。你觉得那里有一种类似的东西吗？我认为有一种——非常遥远的迴响，但是……对殉难的记忆，我想是的。殉难的力量。两者都配得上殉难者的称号。是的，我想是的。
about maybe the resentment that's generated as well as the kind of sympathy perhaps then you get also i mean maybe i'm stretching things here but you get the sense of what was at stake when henry viii destroyed beckett's tomb the power of a martyr can be very dangerous yeah to those who feel menaced by it this is absolutely heroic work tom to link this well no no podcast in history has ever tried to draw a power a link between the death of thomas do you think do you think that there's a kind of parallel there i think there's a kind of i mean mean, very distant echo, but... The memory of martyrdom, I suppose so. The power of martyrdom. Both rank as martyrs. Yes, I suppose so.
我的意思是，在伤膝河大屠杀中，也有一些我们之前讨论过的“屠杀无辜者”事件的微弱回响。我的意思是，有那种大量无辜平民被屠杀的场面。是的。好吧，美国历史上确实有过这样的大屠杀。美莱村事件，或者不管怎么说，我不记得怎么发音了，人们被屠杀。是的，好吧，美国历史上确实有过这样的大屠杀。美莱村，或者不管怎么说，我不记得怎么发音了，越南人的大屠杀。那是发生在
I mean, there's a slight echo in the Wounded Knee Massacre as well of the Massacre of the Innocents, which we talked about earlier. I mean, there's that, you know, the spectacle of large numbers of innocent people being slaughtered. Yeah. Well, American history has these massacres. So My Lai, or whatever, I can't remember how to pronounce it, people being slaughtered yeah well american history has these massacres so me lay me lie or whatever i can't remember how to pronounce it uh the massacre of vietnamese um it's during the
越南战争是美国历史上另一场著名的大屠杀。再说一次，有些人——我的意思是，我怀疑这个播客的听众里不会有很多这样的人，但总会有那么一些人——一提到这个就会翻白眼，说：“哦，天哪，闭嘴吧，别那么‘觉醒’（woke）了。”真是“觉醒”的废话，借用人们在“历史世界杯”上对埃塞尔斯坦胜利的评价。我的意思是，我不认为这是
vietnam war is the other great famous massacre in uh american history um and again i mean that's there are some people i mean i don't i doubt many listeners of this podcast to this podcast but there will be some people who kind of roll their eyes at mention of this and say, oh, God's sake, you know, shut up, don't be so woke. What woke Tosh, to quote people about the victory of Athelstan in the rest of history World Cup. I mean, I don't think it is
“觉醒”的废话，但事实就是如此。既然我是仲裁者。是的，你可以决定。我已经决定了。它不是。好吧。我们只是在胡扯。我们现在只是在瞎扯，我们，我们，我们……但我也认为，在严冬的深处，悲剧具有一种特殊的品质，一种神圣的品质，汤姆。也许……这是红色与白色的结合，是鲜血与白雪。这里面有些东西。是鲜血与白雪。嗯，我不认为这也是
woke Tosh, but there you go. And since I'm the arbiter. Yeah, you can decide. I have decided. It's not. Right. We're just wittering. We're just scrambling now we are we are we are we are um but i i think also it it um there's a particular quality to um to tragedy in the depth of winter a sacral quality tom maybe um it's it's it's a conjunction of red and white it's the blood and the snow there is something something. It's the blood and snow. Well, I think isn't that also
因为在流行文化中，印第安人的故事通常被认为是在沙漠的酷热或平原的酷热中展开的。而事实是，结局——
because the Indian story is usually perceived in popular culture. The Cowboys and Indians story is perceived as having played out in the heat of the desert or the heat of the plains. And the fact that the end,
最后一章发生在冰雪之中，这让它显得更加悲惨。寒冰。好吧，带着这个轻松愉快的心情，我们要向大家告别了。我们明天还会回来，
the final chapter is in the snow makes it feel all the more kind of tragic. The ice. Yeah. Anyway, on that cheery note, we will bid you farewell. We'll be back tomorrow
带来12月30号的内容。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
with December the 30th. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
12月30日再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。